I'll show you how we can add
breakpoints in our code.
Go ahead and click on the screen bug icon
to attach the debugger.
We'll go to the Settings menu.
In the SettingsActivity,
I'm going to add two breakpoints
in the onPreferenceChange method.
I'm going to add a breakpoint at line 59
in the case of a ListPreference
when it's about to set the summary.
I'm also going to add a breakpoint
at line 63 when it's not a ListPreference
and it sets the summary.
Let's go into the app to try it out.
Tap on the Location
and change the postal code.
If you hit OK then it triggers
the breakpoint to stop right here.
These are the values
of the variables at this time,
and we see the new postal code here.
You can step over or into the method
for more details, or you can hit Play
to continue, or Stop to stop the debugger.
Let's hit Play to continue. And then
we see that the UI has been updated
so that the preference summary
is the new postal code.
Let's try it for Temperature Units.
We tap here, and then select Imperial.
It triggers this breakpoint
in the ListPreference case.
We hit Play to continue,
and then we see
that Imperial is now
the preference summary.